right this is gonna be a slightly more
improvised video than normal for two
reasons one it is really cold here I
don't want to move on her but also
because I didn't know that I was going
to be passing through Schengen a little
town in Luxembourg on the borders with
France and Germany until today but here
I am standing next the international
border the Moselle River and that border
is a little bit weird and I wasn't going
to do another video about a weird borax
have done that years ago I went to towns
of baldness sound ball a hertog in
Belgium in the Netherlands where the
borders are incredibly complicated and
twisted thanks to history but that's no
video that I'm not really proud of them
frankly it's not that interesting I only
managed about a minute of script before
I had to go into a diversion on
sovereignty and why we even have borders
in the first place
strange borders often make for great
video titles but there's not really much
to talk about other than huh that's
weird
which is also why I've never been to the
island that changes country every six
months between France and Spain because
once you're there what is there to say
but yes that's weird but it turns out
this border raises a different question
if you look on the map there is a try
point just over there to the west of an
island that's where France Germany and
Luxembourg all meet and it was there
actually on a boat docked at that try
point why the Schengen Agreement was
signed why most of the countries of the
EU all the ones that have the flags here
decided to open their internal borders
but that try point out there is not
strictly true the border between Germany
and Luxembourg doesn't follow the
Moselle River the border is the Moselle
River and that's an important
distinction in most cases international
borders that follow rivers are defined
as following the center line which
raises questions in itself because
rivers can erode the banks and change
paths sometimes but borders are at least
usually defined as a line of
theoretically zero width which is how
map makers market but here Germany and
Luxembourg share the river north of
France it is a condominium under the
treaties they've signed they both have
full control over it which means it if
you're standing on the north tip of that
island or on that bridge up there you
are in both countries at the same time
not in terms of having a foot on each
side although that may well be how the
locals treat it and that's certainly how
the signs and market but no standing on
that bridge above the water all of you
is in both countries simultaneously
this international border is a shape not
a line it's two-dimensional although I
guess it's three-dimensional if you'd
count depth half-hour of research and I
can't tell you why they made that
decision or what the legal result would
be if you tried to commit a crime on
that bridge or on a boat on the river I
even asked the folks at little European
Museum just over there and they didn't
know the answer although they do have a
lovely little display of all the border
guard hats that the Schengen Agreement
made obsolete I suspect that the answer
would be treat it as if it's a line it's
easier and that's what I mean when I say
there's not much to talk about here
because that's one of the wonderful
things about borders like this when you
can walk between three countries as
easily as you can walk between counties
or towns or neighborhoods it's a lot
easier to say huh that's weird and just
get on with your life
you